Beyonce and jay-z announced their joint
tour and Twitter is having a field day
Plus why fans are in an uproar about
Taylor Swift's delicate video it's
happened in the on the run to tour is
coming y'all The Beehive has been
buzzing about this since last week about
jay-z and Beyonce going on another joint
tour and today the couple officially
announced they are on the run again in
hitting stadiums in 21 cities across the
u.s. this summer Queen Bee posted a
black and white video of the couple with
moments from their first on the run tour
though shows back in 2014
generated over 100 million dollars that
makes sense because Beyonce got us over
drafting and setting up GoFundMe pages
for these tickets pre-sales were on the
run to go on sale in two days and less
than a month before her headlining gig
and Coachella and listen I'm not the
only one struggling at Fred Wilson said
it best the fact that the pre-sale
starts in two days Beyonce not even
giving you time to make a transfer from
your savings to checking that Stephen
also looking for a more bang for his
buck tweeting on the run to better mean
beyonce is releasing a new album because
if she thinks I'm gonna pay $500 to see
her perform her old music she is
absolutely right you know I'm also
banking on some new music considering
both J and B's last album's address
their marriage woes and ain't nobody got
time for that
like I'm trying to have a good time
in fact at Sydney tweeted beyonce has
only taken jay-z on tour because he
can't be trusted home alone for five
months y'all savage but that's why I
love you the hive is so dedicated no
matter what check this out I don't know
why we're still running but B and J I'm
their same but that is why
[Music]
for a small donation VMI venmo you could
get me two on the run - this is your
chance to say I won't sit by while the
Beyonce stance suffers all right
well now that that's over let's talk to
Taylor Swift she's about to hit the road
- with her reputation tour and last
night during the iHeartRadio Music
Awards
Taylor premiered the video for delicate
and the girl is dancing like no one is
watching
[Music]
so here's the thing fans on social media
are accusing Taylor of taking a little
too much inspiration from a 2016
fragrance commercial directed by Spike
Jones they were quick to point out
similarities in the facial expressions
plus the two women also escape the
personas at a black-tie event with
unusual choreography Taylor's rep would
not comment but what do you guys think
is the inspiration for Taylor's video
we'll see if we get Taylor dancing in
the rain live on her upcoming tour last
night et spoke with Camila Cabello who
is opening for Taylor and as you can
tell it's a dream come true so how does
that how does the conversation go do you
text like emojis or does that have to go
through managers my tailor says you know
you're coming on to work me she was
telling me about it because we talk all
the time and you know for me it's a
dream come true because she knows like I
think when I first met her four years
ago I was like you know I really love
you I came up to her when at the VMAs
and I was like man I really look up to
you you really inspire me and she was
one of the people that made me want to
start songwriting so it's really amazing
and also you know with Charlie XCX it's
gonna be you know it's gonna be like a
big like summer party which is so
similar because you are so independent
and powerful and you kind of stand for
the same things which I love so it's
gonna be an huge stadium so it's like
it's this is no small little theater you
know I'm saying also at the iHeartRadio
awards was cardi B who ruled the night
not only did she open the show with a
medley of her hits she took home two
Awards including Best New Artist and had
this message for her haters and I want
to thank my haters too because
because they'd be downloading my stuff
so they can hear it it's all crap Abadi
but it benefits me
and with that cardi B is the gift that
keeps on giving I head over to ET online
comedy for more of cardis best moments
at the I Heart award where she also
announced when we can expect her debut
album okay anyway it's day five of my
vegan life so far so good but make sure
you're following me on instagram because
i need to be held accountable yah
Coachella is right around the corner